okay next question Dr zaka is um could
you explain what the recommended acts
are on the day on the day of
Eid the first thing is that you should
have Gul it's mentioned in m page 240
Hadi number 4
to8 Naf narrates with him that abdah
Omar with him he used to have a bath he
used to have Gul before proceeding for
the E Salah so it's a Sunnah that you
have to have a bath before going to the
Mah for the E
Salah number two is that it's also
Sunnah that you should wear good clothes
Ador yourself you should beauy yourself
you can wear new clothes you can put
Coil In Your Eyes put oil in the hair
you can wear perfume but natural all
these things for the men the women are
not recommended to wear perfume and on
themselves when they go out B they
should be in hijab they should be veiled
this is talking about the men Point
number three is that the prophet always
had dates before he left his house for
offering the E Salah it's mentioned
Hadith ofari Vol number two the book of
two eids Hadith number 953 the prophet
ate dates before he left the house for
offering the E Salah and the fourth Act
is that the each Salah should be offered
in a
Mah in a place maybe on a big ground
maybe in the town on the outskirts of
town where all the people can gather in
one place it's mentioned in the Hadith
of
bukari volume number two in the book of
two eids had number
956 the prophet malli wasallam on E day
he went to the Mah and he offered the
Salah and offering each Salah in Mah is
a Sunnah rather than in the mosque
though the prophet
is there which is mentioned in s bukari
number two the superiority of M har and
Madina Hadith number 11 190 the prophet
said praying in my mosque that is
praying in
m is better than offering thousand times
Salah anywhere else except M Haram
that's Makkah but yet for the E Salah
the prophet preferred leaving his own
mosque and going to the ID going to the
Mah that means during each specific Ally
praying there is preferable than praying
even in the
mosque this is the importance of praying
in the musah further more it's mentioned
inkari number two in the book of two
eids Hadith number 986 it says that
mhamad sallallah Ali wasallam when he to
return back after offering each Salah to
his home he us to return back in a way
different from the way he had gone that
mean the route of the Prophet going from
the house to the Mah was different and
the root of coming back was different
and this was maybe because he wanted to
Salam to the different people you know
both the ways and maybe the blessing
would be two different types of people
and various reasons given by people why
he did that furthermore it's very
important that each Salah should PR in
the Mah as I mentioned earlier the
Gathering is bigger psychologically is
better and we can you know show the god
conscious of Allah subhana tala further
it's the Sunnah that we should go early
to the musah the earlier the better you
know so that we can be in time we
Hasting to do the good deed it's also
mentioned
ofi Hadith number
530 that the prophet peace be upon him
he's to go on foot when to go to the
musah offering each Salah he's to go on
foot so Sunnah to go walking to offer
your Salah and it's mentioned in the
Hadith
of number 171
that prophet wasallam he used to recite
the immediately after leaving home till
the time he reached musah till the time
he finished his Salah to say the and the
most authentic T is what had recited
mentioned in Al
[Music]
and he recite allahar
Allah he to recite
Allah meaning Allah is the greatest
Allah is the greatest there's no one
worthy of worship besides Allah subhana
wa taala Allah is the greatest Allah is
the greatest all praise are du to Allah
subhana tala this is T and it should be
recited the moment you leave the home
till the time you read the Salah till
the Salah is to mallam so these are the
few recommended acts that should be done
during the E day well justak here for
your answer Dr Zaki